Let's go next to why don't we go? There's just
so many people interested in getting on today.
It's hard to know where to go. Why don't we go to
Luke from Minnesota next. Luke, you're on the air.
Hello. So I was wondering what you would think of
a potential boycott of the 2020 Olympics in China?
You mean the 2022 Olympics in China?
That's 2022.
Yes, yeah. We talked about this on the bonus
show earlier this week. There's three types
of boycotts that you can do. There can be
a diplomatic boycott where the athletes go,
but the country doesn't send representatives.
It's sort of like a diplomatic protest.
You can do an athletic boycott where you don't the
country doesn't send any athletes. And then you
can also do what's called the boycott lite, which
is diplomats and athletes go. But the diplomats
make statements that are critical of of the
government. I I tend to think that I want the
athletes there. And we've had so many examples
of conflict between countries during which
athletes still went. And I don't particularly
care about the Olympics, but I think it's
a good message to say that the athletic community
is going to compete in a way that is not tied
to politics and let the diplomats do what they
want. So if they want to do a diplomatic boycott,
OK, if they want to do boycott lite. But
I would definitely send send the athletes.
All right. Thank you so much.
That was a very good answer.
All right. Thank you very much. Yeah, that's
we'll talk more about that, I think,
as we get closer to that point in time